- [Instructor] So it looks
like we have some angry cats
on our hands, meow, yeah they seem angry.
And what we want to do is
think about how can we separate
these angry cats 'cause the
only thing worse than an angry
cat is 12 of them coordinating
potentially to take over
the world.
And so what we're going to
think about is can we divide
these 12 angry cats into equal
groups and just for the sake
of this video let's say we
want to divide them into three
equal groups, how could we do that?
Well let me see if I can do
it, let's see maybe this is one
group right over here,
maybe this is another group
right over there, and then
this is another group.
Are those three equal groups?
Let's see this top group has
four, this group has three,
and this one has five, so no
these aren't three equal groups
so that won't work it has
to be not just three groups,
three equal groups.
So let me see if I can
do something different.
I could have these four in a
group and then I could have
these four in a group, I think
this is going to work out
this time.
And then I could have
these four in a group.
And as I just said out loud
all of these groups have
exactly four angry cats in
them, which is a little bit
more manageable and so this works out.
I have just divided the
12 into three equal groups
and how many cats are in
each of those equal groups?
Well we can see very clearly
that there are four cats
in each of those equal groups.
So the way to think about
division in this example is you
started with 12 and you
divide it into three equal,
three equal groups and we
ended up with four cats,
four cats per group.
Now what if we wanted to
interpret it slightly differently?
So let's bring in 12 more
angry cats which is always
a dangerous thing to do but
we're doing it for the sake
of learning so it's worth it.
Meow, yep more angry cats.
And now let's imagine 12
divided by three, 12 divided
by three, but this time we're
not going to think about
the three as three equal groups,
we're going to think about
it as 12 divided into groups of three.
So groups of three.
So each of the equal groups
will have three in them
and so then that's going to
tell us how many equal groups
we're able to have.
So let's do that, let's
create groups of three.
So let's see that's a
group of three angry cats
right over there.
This is another group of three
angry cats, this is a group
of three angry cats and then
this is a group of three
angry cats.
So how many equal groups of
three angry cats do I have?
Well I have one, two, three,
and four equal groups.
So if I want to take 12
angry cats and divide them
into groups of three I
end up with four equal,
four equal groups.
So there you have it, there's
two different ways that
we can imagine division.
And the same exact division
expression 12 divided by three,
you could do it as 12 being
divided into three equal
groups and then the answer
would be how many things
per group.
Or you could say hey 12
divided into groups of three
and then that would end
up with four equal groups.